most people have that idea and they look
down upon them of their heads
because of this idea that you know
there's a straight path to agenda who
are these four guys who showed up 200
years after the process and why is their
school so
prominent the reason why us is
and say that they are in line with the
quran and
they are in line with what allah wants
is because
what they use as proofs does not stray
from the quran
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the reminder is that no matter where you
are in life you know you don't know
where you're gonna be tomorrow
you could be feeling amazing one day and
then literally lose your iman like that
right the prophet sent him said that
there will come a time where a person is
a believer in the morning and at night
they're a disbeliever
all right assalamu
dear brothers and sisters i wasn't gonna
leave today but i guess i
am um today i don't know what we're
talking about but you are joined here
with the uh the originals
and you got fletcher number one number
one guest that we had
number one guest everyone so
we decided that we're gonna bring it
back on and uh
fire why don't you just why don't you
take it away we only brought him back
60 episodes later bro
yeah 60 episodes in six months not bad
for six months
i'm surprised more at uh how we didn't
even miss a single week
since we started the podcast
alhamdulillah
what's going on in our kansas
all good alhamdulillah it's very hot
right now though
which is kind of sucks
but you wanna do you wanna let some of
the viewers know a little bit about you
the the new viewers
and maybe a little bit into why our
kansas is actually called arkansas
all right inshallah
for having me back on i'm excited to be
on the realist
podcast in dunya it's the best title
in all of youtube um see
people who don't know me i was the best
and first guest
on the podcast
my name is fletcher i live in arkansas
not arkansas and
the reason why it's called arkansas
versus our kansas is because
the tribes the native american tribes
that lived here originally
spelt at arkansas but when the
colonizers came
they decided to keep kept keep how it
sounded but
change the spelling so don't ask me i
like it arkansas it's not our kansas
no matter what these guys man mashallah
you're a reaver right
just for the viewers who don't know
brother when did you
i guess get into dean i uh i converted
to islam
on october 31st 2018
i was a junior in high school at the
time
and ever since then just been studying
trying to trying to become a better
muslim trying to please allah the best i
can
that's what i love about islam it's like
bro all four of us
if somebody just saw us they'd be like
okay one is this one is that the other
one's this the other one's that
but we're all muslim alhamdulillah and
that's what i love that
you can look like anything you could
look like you're in a different religion
but you could be muslim you could be any
skin color wearing anything doesn't
matter you still have islam to come back
to
the talk but huge shout out to brother
fletcher for looking
more islamic than all of us or at least
i should say more muslim
than all of us mashallah
before we go in man i had a question it
might be a little too early
because you might think okay maybe this
is something more suited towards the end
but my main question is there's four
madahip there's four sunni
schools of thought and when i don't know
what an
is doing and when you look at uh sunni
islam which is you know the purest form
of islam
unadulterated right straight from the
sunnah
right hence the name sunni islam one
would think that
okay there's only one way there's only
one path
and when they they think of four schools
of thought one might have this inherent
notion that
one might be correct out of all three or
all four and the other three are not
so why do they differ which like what
are these differences in
so maybe go into that bismillah all
right
so you're absolutely right and i think
most people have that idea
and they they might even stray away or
may
look down upon the heads because because
of this idea that's you know there's a
muslim there's a straight path
to allah you know there's a straight
path to agenda that you know why are
these four different schools these four
different
you know who are these four guys who
showed up 200 years after the process
and them and decided to
you know like who are these guys and why
is their school so
prominent why do so many people identify
uh as these
hips and the reason why
us is the uh
yeah the people who are upon the sunnah
follow these form of that
and say that they are in line with the
quran and sun and
they are in line with what allah wants
is because
what they use as proofs does not stray
from the quran
nothing that they are doing is going
against allah and his messenger
for they are actually making the
religion
accessible to us the religion is so
so vast you know thousands and thousands
of
hadith and the quran is so in depth in
its language and
how it's structured that's the reason
why these former
heads are the way they are is because
they they make it easy for us to
understand
uh you know the prophet said he didn't
he didn't write
a book he didn't write a book that
started with tahara than salah then
zakat and hajj
you know he's just the prophet saw and
that's and that's what
these imams that's what these scholars
do
is they make it easy for us because we
aren't scholars in this now we haven't
spent
you know 60 70 years of our life just
studying with them it's
it's been made easy to us we can go
online and look up a
tower we can go on we can go online and
learn fifth we can go to a scholar
in our city in our town and just like
ask a question
because it's been made that easy it's no
longer we don't need a loan
we don't need to go and search you know
manuscripts we don't no longer need
these uh
these as i need these these chains of
narrations to
you know verify if this is true or not
you know
i love latin
i have a question what's your question
with these schools of thought
is one required to follow a school of
thought
so there's two things when it comes to
you know do we need to follow a method
do we need a false full thought
for the lay man the person who
has not studied and and the famous
hanafi scholar
ibn abidine he says the person who does
not have the knowledge
you know who the person who does not
have knowledge
what he needs to do is go to a living
person and ask that fatah
you know his method becomes the one who
asks
men of that scholar there's and there's
no point in for that person to say you
know i'm hanafi i'm shafari i'm maliki
because they're just the per they're
just the lay man
so as the layman you don't need to
follow one
method but when you have a question when
the lame man when the person who does
not know has a question
they need to go to someone that they
trust and ask them
and whatever they say you can't be like
oh no you're wrong
the the say this it's like you don't
know you're the one asking
and so the person doesn't need to know
but the person should not stay in
ignorance and they should
have enough you know patience
enough character to go ask someone and
be humble enough to receive an
answer so what if
someone were to uh
basically just go on this journey let's
say figuratively speaking on their own
they choose not to go to another person
maybe it might be because they want to
you know go into it on their own or
maybe it's because they just don't have
anyone available to them
so would it then be something that this
person
could do or would it just be
you know more reasonable for this person
to seek out someone who has that
knowledge
and is of a certain school of thought
i it's definitely it's definitely more
recommended it's definitely you know
some would even say it's mandatory for
the one that does not know to seek
the one who does know you know if they
are in doubt
and the person who is isolated or is
unable to acquire knowledge
what they do out of ignorance as long as
it's not
going against allah in a [ __ ] way
it's forgivable in that sense but the
person who has that chance and directly
goes away from it to maybe seek their
desires
maybe they want to go find them at their
hips just so they can make it easier for
themselves
this this means following one's desires
seeking them of their heads to fulfill
their desires so if your intention is to
look at the four schools of thoughts as
as a way to get a better understanding
of your religion because you know the
because you can look at the proofs and
understand them that's good
alhamdulillah but if you're doing it to
fulfill their desires you're picking and
choosing then that is
that that is that that in itself is most
definitely forbidden
and we should all try to stay away from
so yeah we should all definitely try to
look for
someone who doesn't know correct me if
i'm wrong but
there's uh i i was looking up uh
the the rulings on i think it was with
angel this one time we were wondering if
lobsters are halal
remember that and i think i googled it
and
there were i think two schools of
thought where lobsters or crustaceans
right like shrimp and all that
are halal and i believe the other ones
they're not or i believe they're halal
for the first but my crew for the other
two
but is that kind of what you're getting
at the notion that you can't be
picking and choosing which one fits your
way of life but rather you should be
seeing which one aligns with your
subjective
truth of reality absolutely yeah i mean
if
if if you come to the conclusion that
lobsters are halal to eat
based off of you know a narration by the
prophesized symptom
then like that's good but if you're
going off to like if you're saying that
lobsters are halal
because i like eating seafood
but like what i'm what i was raised on
what my what my scholar has told me has
said
the otherwise and you were following
your nephs you were following your
desires and i can go for anything like
wiping over socks
you know and in how strict is that and
other things like that all right solid
man
let's let's go into the fundamentals
with our four bismillah
the fundamentals yep so just intro
before um because a lot of people aren't
even familiar
so let's start with the names what are
the four
[Music]
yeah so inshaallah i think i think
before we get into
the four schools of thoughts it's
important to understand
before that even happened before
the hanafi's the the matakis the
shaffers and the
there were there were two main schools
of thought you know even before this
and that was metabolic hijaz and
metabolic
metabolic hijaz more specifically medina
uh you know this was the city that the
prophet saws died in
and it was the first place to establish
a methed a school of thought
because the people that lived there were
the sahaba
and the children of the sahaba and so
these people had an idea of how to
live life how to worship allah how to do
things in life and the front
front runner of this method was imam
and they their understanding of the
religion was based on
you know based on transmission commonly
known as hadith
the people of hadith were the people of
medina
and on the other side the second school
thought was metabolic
more specifically metabolic the city of
kufa in iraq
and they they were based
they it was a very big emphasis on quran
in that city
um kufa was known as the city of quran
you know five out of the ten recitation
styles five out of five out of the ten
kirats come from kufa and the front row
of this method was
imam abu hanifa you know he was the he
was the leader of this
he eventually became known as the
highness and that's later on but
iraq
and they were known to use
people of reasoning logic intellect
understanding
because of the situation they lived in
they needed to use it they were
iraq and kufa was such a mixing pot full
of
greek and chinese and all these
different ideas that they needed to use
their intellect
and there was fabricated hadith you know
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
fabricated hadith they needed to use
intellect
over the hadith unlike
medina and and i'll get into the form of
the hibbs but
imam shafi who is the third imam any
member ahmed
they've taken from both of these schools
you know they've taken from both
medina the school
and so it's important to know that
you know no one's like doing these
outside ideas and they're based on
um they're based on people who they're
based on the sahaba that lived there and
they're based on where the prophet says
he lived in iraq when he migrated after
pakistan
died um and so yeah
we can go into the four schools of
thought so the first school of thought
is the hanafi method whose founder was
name was abu hanifa
not man
and he was born in 80 after hijra and
died 150 after hijra
and he was born in kufa and died in
baghdad all this is in iraq
the second imam is in the maliki methed
named after its founder malik ibn's
and we'll get we can get into his his
lineage is very extensive
um uh and he was the founder of the
maliki method
who died 93 after hijra and died 179
after hijra
and he was born in medina never left
medina and died
when you go into his method you see that
where he lives in medina
is very prominent the third third imam
is the shaffer method school of thought
its founder was muhammad
ibn he is the founder of the shatter he
met them
he was born 150 after hijra died 204
and he was uh born in gaza in palestine
he was raised in mecca and he died in
egypt and his is a very long story of
lots of travels
i see i see our palestinian brother over
here smiling because he knows the
shaftery roots
mashallah the nour on his face
and the last imam for the valleys
who was the founder of the hambury
method of died 160.
or die and i mean 164 died 241
and he was born and died in buffalo dead
but he traveled lots around so those are
that's a good
um names and the founders when they're
born and died perfect
y'all got any questions bro
just respect for memorizing all that
and memorizing those names and just
pronouncing it
pronunciations the pronunciation
oh bro you just pronunciated
uh lining or at least forming some type
of uh
declination towards one school of style
where you kind of want to go a little
bit more into the study
uh than the other ones you have a
preference
yeah so as we were
yeah so i i personally i'm personally
studying the
hamberli method the fourth method of the
schools of thoughts
um that there's for many reasons for
that
um you know living in the united states
you know you don't grow up
on a region that everyone's spawned the
same method
and the people here i had a close friend
who
alhamdulillah he introduced me to it and
i fell in love with it
and that's the one method that i will be
studying inshallah
and that's if if it comes to a time
where i'm able to study another one
inshallah i'd love to
but for now i'm i'm keeping to myself to
the
method um until
until further notice that's a good thing
because
if you chase two rabbits you'll never
catch either one
yeah absolutely yeah so
i have a question bro that that was um
that was a was that a an arabic
proverb or was that an african proverb
you don't remember i don't remember
which one which one
uh disregard just don't worry about it
but um
so question for you bro um
fatwas are basically given from schools
of thoughts
right correct given from scholars yes
from scholars but scholars of select
schools of thoughts correct yes yeah
sometimes
sometimes sometimes so sometimes you
have thought was given that
aren't from like a specific school of
thought
yeah so tawa which is the
the um the plural for a fatwa
a fatwa is given from an individual
scholar so one person
gives fatswa um now that feteswa can be
taken by a school of thought and make it
authoritative
but usually they're they're used in a
specific context at a specific time for
specific people
so like here in america we have
scholars that give fatawa for the people
living in america and so it see it would
be
um it would be odd to take fatah from
people living in arabia and indonesia um
and so yeah so scholars
not not necessarily schools of thought
they derive they derive what is
authoritative
through like by themselves they don't
they don't they don't argue with
other schools or other people to what is
you know
correct according to them so yeah yeah
okay i want to i want to add here um and
also
all of that very informative um in the
amount that i learned and what
how long has been ten minutes subhan
allah
when it comes to schools of thought they
don't just or the scholars of the
schools of thoughts
uh they don't just give these fatah they
don't
you know they don't just offer these
these rulings
in in the fatawa and all of that they
offered the fatawa using a very
specific usual a very specific basically
a method
of deriving these rulings right if we
are going to stay consistent in our
religion
we need a consistent way of deriving
rulings and that's
what the schools of thought do and
that's the only
as far as i know and i'm like a very
very like
low layman right so take my words with a
grain of salt
that's the only real difference between
the schools of thought the method in
which they derive
the rulings what they accept and how
authoritative those are for example
some schools of thought like imam
shafarihim allah will regard
the quran and the hadith on the same
level when it comes to
laws and legislations was they were
regarded on the same exact level
for legislation um but basically all
four schools of thought they they accept
quran hadith and the um
of the the consensus of the companions
they differ on things like thing
something called isan which is what
feels
more right yes there's actually some
schools of thought some scholars that
use that
and for their time they use that um and
things like um the opinions of certain
scholars yeah chaos is very
important as well which i guess in
shortly you'll get into that afterwards
but what i what i want to add here is
that
this is the this is the difference the
method in which they derive these
rulings and i think it's important that
someone if they're going to claim that
they are
humbly or shafi or or maliki or
any school of thought that they at least
understand
what method is being used and that they
understand that that is the difference
in the rulings and that's why people
come to these conclusions
based off their gosul their method okay
so with that being said uh backtracking
a little bit here if i had you had said
when you had asked uh brother fletcher
question you said um
something about your subjective truth
and um what you what you want
is it something like that what was the
exact that you said
pertaining to what pertaining to these
schools of thoughts like when
when you had mentioned the whole lobster
thing yeah we were we were getting on
the notion that
it's in our best interest insha allah to
not follow a school of thought because
it aligns with our
lifestyle you follow and to more come
into a firm understanding of our
interpretations of
you know different verses in the quran
different
hadith basically our islamic moral
universe it's better we come to that
understanding first through knowledge
and then you know find which school of
thought we want to follow
i want to do this one thing but two of
these say it's
the other one states halal so let me
follow the two that says hello so i feel
as guilty
yeah so um what i'm trying to ask you
is like what if you are
not going with your desires you are just
going with your subjective
truth you know what you are logically
coming to
but what you are logically coming to on
different things
are not fully aligning with one school
thought and
are going off each of different schools
of thoughts here
yeah so i guess there's you know
what you're logically inclined to
you know
bro i thought that was the pope or
something there
is is what you're um is what you're
being logically inclined to done with
knowledge
and understanding of the religion or is
it being done with
no knowledge or understanding of
religion so if it's being done with
knowledge and understanding of the
religion if you're able to
look at a hadith for example and you
come to the conclusion that
we'll keep using the example that
lobster has had
then good like go ahead
but if you're going if you come to the
conclusion that lobsters
and like you have no way of really
looking at a hadith for example
and coming to the conclusion that it is
had out you're just kind of like
you know they say it's they say it's
logically makes sense that it's because
you use your own reasoning
then you yourself are in no position to
like use that reasoning because
you've yet to you get to go through
these other important proofs first
you've yet to go through the quran the
hadith and the
sahab which by consensus is as
rami was saying is the sources of proof
that all schools of thought use
you have to go through those three first
before even touching
what you think is right so hello
yeah my bad my bad for uh charming here
y'all the
the the reaver inside of me is coming
out
no problem bro these are good questions
these
questions
yeah i actually i want to add to that
because i feel like an example here
would be helpful
um so let's say it it had to do with
let's say we were talking about like
intimacy right we're talking about like
oral sex or something like that
which yeah okay some people get your
giggles out of the way but
talking about like oral sex or something
for example a lot of people
would have a very superficial way of
looking at the deen they might look at
you know what sex is so you can make
babies babies can't come out of oral sex
so maybe then it's haram you know i
think maybe anal sex is haram for that
same reason
so maybe you know it doesn't make sense
logically speaking oral sex
you should maybe avoid it because i
think it's haram in that case you're
using some kind of
logic but is that deduction correct
is that deduction correct and see that's
this is an issue because
perhaps you know one of the blessings of
intimacy so so you can
have children but that's not all it is
in islam it's
perfectly permissible for you to be
intimate with your husband or wife
regardless of if you're trying to
conceive or not regardless of
whether or not that's the intention so
again going back to schools of thought
when the brother mentioned proofs this
that's exactly what you have to look at
you have to look at the evidences
because the scholars don't look at the
deen in a superficial way
what i the example i gave was very
superficial and that's
that's that's a problem because it seems
logical but it's
actually irrational because it's not
according to the deen
so what the scholars do is they'll
provide the evidences
and they'll say because of these
evidences
and our method of deriving rulings we
conclude that this is halal this is
haram etc etc so if you have two
opposing opinions
you don't roll dice and choose you don't
think i this feels better
you don't think well i want to do it so
i'm going to choose this you look at
their evidences
and you find they have a clear verse
from the quran
they they don't have any of that they're
just using their own logic
well um because of this we can conclude
that
when oh no actually allah says in the
quran xyz
therefore this is haram and also i want
to mention one more thing
in islam things are haram and or sorry
things are halal and so proven haram
there are permissible also proven haram
so if you have a case where it's like
is oral sex allowed and i'm going to end
of this note you're asking is oral sex
allowed
it is allowed until you find evidence is
haram
so if you find an opinion that says it's
haram and you examine those evidences
and it's okay khalas is clear
then okay you can't reject that but if
it's if there's two opposing opinions
one says it's halal
and they give their reasons for it and
the other side
they just cannot prove it's haram they
don't have actual evidences
demonstrating is haram okay then in that
case
where the evidence is lead uh we shall
go in sha allah i just wanted to touch
on two quick things that he said
first thing when rami mentioned in islam
everything's halal until proven haram
these are anything except ibadah or acts
of worship because these are all
haram unless specified the second thing
is when rami said
um you are you can be you know it's
allowed to be intimate with your husband
or wife
he's referring to if you're a man with
your wife
and a woman with your husband
yeah and i just want to add bro like
it's good that you're clarifying like
that and if people have been watching
this podcast y'all y'all will know that
rami
is a big advocate of uh not being
extreme
because when you lean to one extreme
then it gives birth
to the next extreme and it's like if you
really think about it if you're not
analyzing the evidence if you hear
someone say
um oh this is haram someone saying uh
oral sex is haram and you just take it
at face value
well like you you're kind of giving
birth to an extreme
uh ideology here because if you think
about it like if you think oral sex is
haram because of what rami said
where it's like ah well sex is to give
birth
so anal sex you can't give birth to anal
sex you can't give birth to oral sex so
then you can only have sex through the
vagina i was like okay well if sex is
only to give birth
then i guess you're only gonna have sex
when you wanna actually give birth to a
child then right
so then that extremism is basically
gonna make you live in a way
where you're going to be suffering for
no reason
for no reason whatsoever i just i think
it's nice that you uh you put it that
way bro
allah make it uh you know good for the
people i mean europe
but bro imagine going your whole life
with that kind of ideology and then
like realizing on the day of judgment or
in the afterlife that you could have
done whatever you want that was you know
that was halal
you didn't have to restrict yourself to
having sex four times in life
oh my god oh and it's like these these
people that are so extreme they'll
probably think to themselves
ah well you know what if i made it to
jannah it's okay
you know i'd rather be in jannah than
have had oral sex
or i've had sex more than four times in
my life but it's like dude
it's like brother gabriel said this uh
holier than the prophet syndrome i was
like dude do you think
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
only had sex
when it was time to procreate i'm sorry
i don't i don't think it was like that
i don't think it was like that
kind of luck oh no i want to bring it
back to fletcher inshallah because i
want to learn
more about the madahim so which school
of thought did you say you were studying
again did you say it was humbly
yeah so let's since you're studying that
you know in particular
can you tell us about their soul and
about their
their method or anything interesting
about them specifically
sure yeah we can go over there so
means sources of proof just for anyone
that uh is what they use to derive their
rulings
so he used
he started with the quran
so not the quran
it's quran and he derived what was an
authentic hadith
is just as authoritative as the quran
they were both wahi they were both
revelation
um then he went with the ijmat the
consensus of the sahiba of course and
then his third proof was
the sayings of the companions
which would differ from the ajmat that
we just talked about that consensus
a difference of opinion of the sahaba
but it's backed up with a divine text
you know it's not them just saying
something but
what they say can be backed up with
their own
use of divine text um
oops this is a pope again
but so if a sahabi says something and no
other sahabi disagrees with it then it
is law
so if it's a if it's a hobby if a
companion says something
or does something that the prophet says
that he said the prophet did and no one
disagrees with it then it itself is law
even if it goes against the
consensus and um
his fourth his fourth opinion or his
fourth also
he used which is very specific to the
method which
to the people who really like hadith the
people that identify as
hadith they they like this opinion of
him ahmed because
his fourth of soul was using weaker
hadith
you know first you use that quran the
quran in
authentic hadith his fourth opinion is
weaker and during his time it was known
as
hadith and mean you know that we don't
use
is not good um but during his time that
those
what they what they considered was
hadith that that had was missing the
sahabi
that was missing the companion that
heard it from the prophet saw
um and in in in hadith study this isn't
a bad thing
inshallah if if you guys get fareed back
on i'm sure he could go into depth about
what this is
um so like for example what a murder
hadith
narrated that the prophet saws said this
you know there's obviously something
missing
here you know we're missing a companion
um but this is still it's still a weaker
hadith
but it's not straight straight out you
know fabricated
it's not weak to the point where we
can't trust it because we know that we
can trust hassan ambassador
he's a very reliable person narrator of
hadith and everything
so it's kind of it would be odd to say
that
he the great this great imam is a liar
he made this haditha
and so we can trust that he got it from
a reliable source
now that the grading system that we have
nowadays is the grading system of imam
admitting
and the hadith that the imam ahmed would
be using right here would be
counted as hasan so
they're they're weak but not so much so
that we can't derive
meaning from them and partial rulings
from them
and his fifth and the fifth i'll hurry
up
analogy logical reasoning using the
intellect what we were talking about
after going through all these proofs
and um you know finding every way to try
to
find a proof for each of those he at
that point you can finally use your own
analogy your own opinion
but imam ahmed was very specific about
it he said only in necessity
only an absolute necessity you can use
your chaos your opinion
or not your opinion but your analogy um
he he kind of took the the opinion
between malik and shaffer
because imam malik was very strict and
disregarded the ass altogether
well i remember he used it he used it
partially as well
um and so only after finding those four
points he gives us fatwa
with accordance to the quran and sun
using his analogy
but never attributing it to rasool allah
never saying that
i'm using my analogy the prophet sent
him would have done this
did this and so these are very specific
to him
allah
you said analogy and i feel like people
are going to be like what isn't
an analogy like you're comparing this to
that and
you give some kind of weird like proverb
or something weird
an analogical deduction um
is another way we can we can term it
that's what my teachers
yeah so it's basically a logical
deduction where you take
one thing and you use basically a
premise
you have a key point and then you use
sound logic and come to a conclusion
one example my teacher gave us is having
the mushaf the quran the book
of the quran with the written words of
the quran in it in the bathroom
is haram you can't do that okay what
about if it's like
on my phone i have quran open on my
phone and it's digitally displaying you
know bismillah
alhamdulillah so on and so forth is that
haram as well
analogical deduction so what some
scholars did is they said
the reason it's haram to have the book
open is because that's the words of
allah
being displayed it's there right same
thing with the phone it's still
physically there therefore they come to
the conclusion that it is haram
even though they didn't have phones in
the time of the prophet so the quran
doesn't mention it specifically the
hadith doesn't mention it the the
sahabah don't mention it the scholars
don't mention it because phones were a
very recent invention
so they didn't have this so in that case
they have to use analogical deduction
that's like uh as the brother mentioned
this is like
like worst case scenario this is what
you go to when you have
no quran sunnah sahaba or
scholarly opinion from the classical
scholars i'm talking about the issue
it's a brand new issue
so i hope that people helps inshaallah
that's good that's a what was the what
was the
translation used for it the the
analogical
yeah analogical deduction analogical
deduction that's good i remember that
that's a better that's a better way than
saying analogy analogical deduction
and please take your time when you're
talking about these things don't feel
rest at all don't feel like oh i need to
hurry or anything like that
i appreciate it exactly i got you and
guys i have like i don't know how much
let me see how much
percentage battery i got four percent
battery left
so um if y'all see me just dip y'all
know what happens
sounds good just like the live stream
no live stream bro you got it
what are your thoughts on this on this
zoom profile picture
i really like it yeah i'm a big fan of
it yeah
i took it in iceland bro when he was in
the back seat
what a shame that these uh viewers can't
see it
i know what an actual shame bro it
doesn't they may not see it
nah they just see his name written just
like they won't see your profile picture
oh every time the pope shows up yeah
yeah yeah
that threw me on was i think i really
thought it was the pope
that was a that was a snapshot i took
while i was giving a [ __ ] about one week
i thought it was a really cool action
shot so i was like yeah
yeah bro
wait what is next on the menu
um i'm not too sure we can go through
i got whatever you guys want yeah i got
a question
um i don't know if you even mentioned
this
maybe you did please let me know if you
did mention this or if you did mention
this fletcher
but um you chose the uh what was the
school you chose again
i can't that's what i said
there you go did you say why you chose
this school
i i didn't give like uh like a
big reasoning for it i could i could
expand this here
[Music]
partially was i i at the beginning
when i when i wanted to kind of study
islam
like uh you know gain and try to try to
gain knowledge
for some for some reason allahu adam fit
deriving rulings
uh learning about jurisprudence it stuck
to me for some reason i really like the
idea of
learning about what we can and cannot do
how we can and cannot do it
um because they're they're just like
amazing um scholars you know
throughout the history they've been
amazing scholars
uh people who memorize hadith and teach
hadith they're very um
they're very strict with how they teach
and how they learn they're very
straight to the point that you know they
memorize
uh sahih bukhari and now they're they're
jazza's
now they derive release from that and
it's if you don't
and not all of them are like that
they're just very particular and that
with me that hibs they're very lenient
and that every i've learned from or
or seen online or read from they're very
lighthearted and it just
it stuck to me they seemed very like
kind um
people and i wanted to learn from them
and so
um when looking at my heads i didn't
really have like a
reason as to why i chose the hambury
besides that
it was presented to me in a way that was
like
it seemed as if that's like
like it's it's it's usual was presented
to me
and i would say it was the only one that
was kind of presented to me in a way
that was like
very um easy to understand like the idea
of that
i got that weaker hadith that meant that
made a lot to me because when you when
you
revert to islam when you come to islam
when you when you study islam
um you have this idea of quran so you
want you want those a hadith
and so allahu adam i really can't give
like
this is why because this uh
you know his students were this the the
scholars are that
i really can't give a reason as to just
it seemed like a great method
and since i've studied it i'm i do not
claim that i'm a humbly i'm not fletcher
alhamdulillah you know
the people who who um who do that
without having proper understanding of
the entire method
they're they're living in a world that
you know that they don't have yet
so no one should identify as that i'm
this than that and you're wrong in that
um just i've i fell in love with the
story of imam ahmed i fell in love with
the story of his students
and i fell in love with um just these
names and the books and the way they
they derive from them and that when i um
when i when i hear that the chain of the
hambali method going from imam ahmed to
contemporary scholars it's really like i
know that name i love that name this you
know
just all these scholars it's just like
it touches me and
that's just from learning it's um and
i'm sure if i was a manager i'm sure if
i
would study the heinous method it would
be the same way like i love you be my
matic he's my
he's one of my favorite just people to
learn about i love him
and i always said if i if i didn't study
the hambury method i would study the
manicurism yeah and i'm i look very mad
at you right now with my moroccan
so i'm sure that was confusing at first
yeah bro so you fell in love with these
things
yeah absolutely so have you fallen in
love with the
collision yet
i was wondering when you'd bring it up
once again as i said on the last video
my wife is in the other room and i'm not
going to say anything
but it is
there it is mashallah yeah fire you are
you are muted bro i heard you laughing
even though you were muted
if she was in the other room and you
were truly against it it wouldn't matter
you just say you were against it
that's true but the fact the fact that
she's in the other room
and you feel some type of way shows that
you feel some type of way
bro and it is in the quran
i'm pretty sure speaking of them and i
have all four sunni schools of thought
no problem with no issues with that
absolutely no why of course it wouldn't
be
yeah i don't think anyone i don't think
anyone who goes against belgium can even
really be muslim
depending on how they go against it like
oh
on oh man just on his favorite topic
yeah unfortunately
watch she comes back in like 10 seconds
just
hey you guys done collisiony yeah bro
oh
[Laughter]
there we go we got like 10-ish minutes
left
you don't want to chop it up about what
i mean
i got a question for romney growing up
in your
family household it's just my assumption
knowing your
background did you grow up in a
chafee based filthy household
yeah so i mean first and foremost my
family wasn't very
uh very religious to the point where
they would actually look
at the fatah were given and be like you
know i'm shaking
allah and in that madahib they say this
so it's never been of any occurrence to
me and i didn't even know until i
actually asked
my mom maybe less than a year ago
and i found out we were actually shafi
no we did follow them uh that meant
subhan allah but i think my school does
as well
and myself i actually leaned towards
imam shafir kim allah
in that that because you know how you
mentioned
hadith right people of basically the
people of opinion the people of um
hadith and sunnah and all that um
imam shafi rahim allah from what i i
learned from what i was taught he was
basically in the middle
right so he didn't he didn't lean
towards one or the other he accepted
both in a fairly balanced way and that
was something i looked at i'm like
subhanallah
um i like that about him and i like that
about
the the school of thought because i felt
like it was it was very encompassing
um and it's it's not to the point where
he would take some random
shaykh's opinion over you know a
mutawatter or ahad hadith
or something crazy like that but it was
in a very balanced way masha allah
from you know as a layman from what i
could tell so
that's kind of the the rundown of me and
in
the shafi mathem
what about you did you grow up in a
household that
seemed to be particular to one school of
thought
no no i was genuine just
genuinely sunni islam
to to be brief no specific
madhab
very cool man there's something that
by the way is anything off the table
like can i ask anything
sure i guess yeah all right there's
something on my mind bro that i always
wanted
and before we wrap it up you coming into
islam
you mentioned your parents were very
supportive alhamdulillah that's very
rare
but i love that for you that you had
that
somewhat lack of a better word smooth
transition into
into the theme um at least as far as
familial matters go
but that being said um how has your
relationship with them
i know we briefly touched a bit on the
on the live but how has it changed
um and and do you
do you feel this inclination all the
time to just
want them to come into the theme or is
it kind of like
you wait for them to
almost have allah will it for them and
let them you know have their own
ordained time
that's a great question i touched a
little bit on it on the live stream
um and that's yes
when when coming to islam uh i i in a
very rare case for example
had a very smooth transition that's a
that's a great way to describe it
when it comes to familial matters and so
when when you see when i see my parents
for example and this is only
only what i can say to my myself and
every reaver has this feeling
just in different ways of course is that
for my example like they they're very
understanding of the religion
and so when i when i say hey i gotta go
pray
they understand when i when i'm making
somewhere
they don't i mean at first they kind of
were like what's but after i told them
about it they were just
fine with it um and that's when i when i
decided to leave wearing a thobe or
start wearing a kufi everywhere we go
even with my parents
they were very just accepting of it and
so
i would say even more to the fact that
they are accepting
it's it it's even more in my hearts
to want them to be muslim
even more than a convert for example
that has a family that
you know kicks them out of the house and
never talks to them and that's
um maybe the only they only ask for when
they really need them
and these are extreme examples i ask a
lot to make it easy for every convert to
a stem
and so it's definitely a thing
that's you really want them to be muslim
that you try
everything you you bring up the quran
you you talk
you give them you give them a quran you
say hey did you you read your book you
know did you read the book i gave you
did you
read the seerah book i gave you you know
it's like i really like the tsunami you
bring up points you talk about the
things you're studying and they see how
much you love it
and that the fact that they still you
know you're expecting them to just go
you're right
part of it is that you really want them
now
but allah knows when and allah allah
when that
when that is if it is all i can do my
all i can do now is make dua
try my best have that character that
adab and do everything i can
um and allahu allah dua is underrated
man
have you ever read the sealed nectar i
personally haven't read that theodore
book
i was speaking uh i might you know take
that up because i was speaking with uh
brother rami last night on a walk
about just wanting to go in on you know
syrah
and just being more of a student of
knowledge and learning more because it's
never too
early um it's also never too late and
i was looking into that book i was
considering it but
for for people that are new to their
journey
right to learn about the seerah maybe
even the companions
of the prophet history
just knew into all of this
let's imagine they were where you were
2018
what steps could you point them towards
what direction
to a person who like just converted to
islam just accepted islam
they maybe or may not have learned
fatiha
in arabic they're praying and they're
kind of like okay what do i do now
like isn't this it yeah no i mean
the best advice i can give for a new
muslim
and some people have it as soon as they
convert where they just
immediately want to start learning some
people are just
they're very slow with it some people
get it 10 years down the line i've i've
met a brother
he's been muslim for eight years now and
that he now wants to start learning how
to read the quran
because like he feels like it's empty
from them and i'm just like subhanallah
i started doing that
six months into me being muslim and i'm
just like that
that's not everyone's journey and it's
just like it's um
so first thing i can just say is just
you know
learn your religion i would say learn
the seerah and learn how to read quran
whether or not you know how to fully
understand it but to get that barakah
to get that just that that
accomplishment of literally reading
lines of arabic
you know the words of allah it's the
best thing you can do it really is
um yeah i mean
that's really i mean learn your religion
and that's for everyone i mean for
literally everyone you need to learn
your religion
even if you're a doctor you're a
mechanic you're an engineer
you need to know your religion
oh
it's been a great episode masha allah um
a lot was covered
i was like mentally dead for like most
of it to be honest so forgive me
um but alhamdulillah fletcher
so it's only fitting that you you look
up to him as well
um bless you and have mercy
i mean
it just reminds me of all these these
stories we hear
because you know on patreon we have
different life tiers where people can do
calls with us
and they can you know come with you know
different consultations and
we hear so many stories about even
people that are into the deen
and you know even their parents are into
the deen now but they just have these
issues they want to talk about it's like
it never ends right and it just reminds
me that it's always going to be
a struggle all right if you're doing a
facade allah then at least
you know where you're going with the
struggle if you're kind of
aimless don't really know where you're
going that's what i love about the deen
and everything is clear there was also
one more thing that
sheikh abdul rahim mccarthy shared with
us on an episode that
as a muslim we have no excuse to be
bored
right like there's no excuse there's
always something to do
yeah even if you're praying fast
there's always something you could do
all right
subhanallah that's very true but
unfortunately we make lots of
lots of lots of excuses nowadays um and
this is something that you know i think
everybody struggles with
where it's just it's just that time
procrastination
is it's really hitting people hard so um
subhanallah i guess my advice on that
would would be
um remember allah and remember the
barakah and remember
the the good that can come out of it and
remember that you know sometimes it's
not really a choice
you know it's not a choice whether you
want to read the quran or not like in
your lifetime
um when you read it okay that's up to
you but you can't completely neglect it
your whole life this is the
book of allah and you're going to stay
away from that come on man don't be
don't be an ignoramus get
um you were mentioning the sealed nectar
and this little bit this just one little
thing i wanted to put in
um i want to check with man's videos he
talks about
um cedar books the recommendations for
cedar books and he was saying that
the like the best cedar book that you
can find
especially in the english language is
the sealed nectar like i would
i myself need to read it this is for me
as a reminder for myself
and that everyone else if they're
looking to read the seerah definitely
real
read the seal marketing that's why
you should get that book yeah yeah
definitely because
again i'm a student of knowledge
romney's a student of knowledge fletcher
is a student of knowledge
um a lot of people come to us with all
these questions and
i always reply to them in the dm's that
i'm not qualified to give you a fatwa
like
you know i'm not a sheikh please you
know like i
we're trying to do good we're trying to
you know
give dawah we're trying to call people
to islam because it's the truth
but at the same time we're just near
ground zero like yeah
we're by no means anywhere near a
scholarly level
and inshallah we get there but at the
end of the day we're just sharing our
journey with y'all
so you know don't ever hesitate to reach
out to us if you have any questions
or reach out to fletcher we're always
here and at the end of the day we're all
a collective
you know thing that's what i love about
ramadan see when ramadan is there
everyone's on deen why is everyone on
bean because everyone else is on deep
right it's easy to pray it's easy to go
to the masjid it's easy to you know
recite quran stay up night praying to
hajj because everyone's doing it
and then when ramadan falls out it's
kind of like that collective
it's not there anymore nobody's out you
know praying uh
you know uh the night prayers anymore
right no one's out there in the masjid
anymore no one's
you don't see that so then we as an
omaha we kind of just we're not on that
anymore
so i feel like that's that's one thing
that i personally
tried and made an effort to this year
when ramadan was done
i wasn't i tried to you know just put in
those extra reps and sets
inshallah and and kind of just try to
stay on it and i notice it's been like
about a month
two months after ramadan right month and
a half ish
uh and it's again super doable
with the grace of allah it doesn't have
to end at ramadan i'm saying that for
myself
because in the past when you know
ramadan was on it my dean was on
on point on 10. after ramadan i was kind
of like okay i'll get it next ramadan
and i always i never ask myself why is
it always next ramadan why do i have to
wait 11 months
why can't i just make it today
that's very good advice yeah very well
as well a lot of people can't bring
themselves to even have that line of
thinking nowadays
without an excuse already popping in
their head so uh may allah bless you bro
and about what you mentioned before this
is a this is a common problem i see
this this is the problem people um you
know muslims on on tick tock and on
youtube and all that
a lot of them are not scholars like
myself i'm on tik tok alhamdulillah and
you know
we have this podcast and everything i'm
not a scholar man
majority of the questions that are asked
to me about islam especially when it
comes to like rulings and is this halal
majority of them the vast majority i say
i don't know man
scholar from
that he says this i know there's another
opinion go ask a scholar i don't know
man
um so that it's a problem when people
let it go to their head and they feel
like they need to give an answer
um despite them not knowing then they
kind of make something up so may allah
protect us from that
i mean you know i mean i mean that's not
a
hey guys if you made it this far comment
down below hashtag bring
fletcher back my next episode of dodger
bro for your time
forever having me on
foreign
the reminder is that no matter where you
are in life you know you don't know
where you're gonna be tomorrow
you could be feeling amazing one day and
then literally lose your iman like that
right the prophet of the senate said
that there will come a time where a
person is a believer in the morning and
at night they're a disbeliever
[Music]
[Music]
um